garrett richards four and five an era of
488.
yeah the one two
that one's golfed out toward the green
monster it's going to be off the green
monster just near the top kicked around
a little bit by verdugo and segura is on
his way to third he heads toward third
ahead first slide and he's got a triple
and the phillies have a runner 90 feet
away
[Applause]
and here's jt and jt lines one to left
field that one's toward the monster off
the top of the scoreboard and it bounces
high in the air he'll get to second
segura will score and the phillies right
out of the gate jump out to a
one-nothing lead they pick up right
where they left off at wrigley fields
here's the o2
swing and a miss he sets down mccutcheon
he goes down hacking so he comes back he
gets a couple of outs
after the triple and the double
and there's velasquez making his 14th
start three and three a 4.50 era and
here's a guy here [ __ ] i tell you what
he's settled into center field but he's
also settling into this lead off
position
1-1
high-fly ball down the line that's deep
into the corner that one's sailing
sailing it is gone
kk hernandez with number 11. and quickly
ties the ball game at 1-1
[Applause]
he gets this
inside fastball
at least i think it was a fastball the
way he hit it he crushed it
now this has become an absolute habit
for [ __ ] hernandez getting the red sox
their first run with the home run that
ball middle in
and somehow he's able to keep that ball
fair
and a lot of times you see a pitch like
that guy swings at it it's foul that
ball stayed in fair territory
and way out of the ballpark
3-1 coming
he takes ball four
so that's a third walk in the inning for
the right-hander velazquez that'll fill
them up for hunter renfro stand the
two-strike pitch
swing a little tapper here to gregoria
so shovel into second he'll get that out
as the run scores they cannot turn two
radugo in and the red sox have the lead
two to one
[Applause]
here is didi gregorius
gregorius lines it to right center field
that'll be in for a base hit hoskins
around second heading to third the throw
goes towards second it was bobbled for a
moment by hernandez and dede slides in
safely and the fills have something
going here in the second they've got
second and third with nobody out and
it's second to third for bowm
lines it the other way and that's in for
a base hit
kick by renfro that's going to score two
as boehm stops it first it'll be a
two-run single and the phillies lead it
three to two and this is a perfect guy
for alec bowman in that situation
here in the bottom of the second inning
brings up bobby dalbeck
a bullet that's fair
that's going to bounce all the way to
the wall
dalbeck taking off easily into second
base with those big strides he's got
himself a double with one down
jd looking to add to his 58 runs batted
in
high fly that one sucked to right racing
back miller still going back turning now
it is gone
into the bullpen
he got that one jerry because he did
yep jd martinez going to right a three
run shot
to put the sox back in front 5-3
fastball right down the middle that
beautiful opposite field swing by j.d
and a quick three runs to the red sox
here's raffy
he drives center field driving back
jankowski all the way turning she's gone
he's done it again
raphael with number 22.
and the red sox on top six to three well
he's for real this kid absolutely amazes
me every day
by what he does look at this fastball
right down the heart of the plate
and he just
tattoos it christian vasquez at third
base
and bobby dalbeck hit first with two
gone
[Music]
bouncing ball and through for a base hit
another run is in
vasquez will score
dalbeck advancing to third
rodugo pulling a single as he picks up
his 35th run bad at him and brings up jd
martinez
2-2 he drives that one toward the gap
nobody out there that skips and that's
off into the bullpen that's going to
cost the red sox a run by going into the
bullpen
so he picks up another rbi is fourth in
the ball game red sox extend the lead to
nine to three
right here's [ __ ] driving one high and
shallow down the right field line is
this going to land fair it is just
inside the line seeing eye automatic
double vasquez can trot home it is 10
3 red sox it's just been that kind of
night
i mean that thing it was perfectly
placed
so now harper is up with a runner at
second base
it's sharply and that's past the diving
bogarts and into right center field a
runoff score as jankowski crosses the
plate it's now 11 to 5. it's an rbi
single for harper
by the way reuben ronald torres is in
the pitch for the philly this is never a
good sign
there's a fly ball to right field
jankowski
is there makes the catch
ground ball
to dede gregorius
and there are two outs quickly
the pitch
and he popped him up
and out into shallow center goes to
reyes and or segura he makes the catch
and he'll keep the souvenir baseball
he's got himself a one two three inning
at fenway park
gene segura began the game
by rocketing a triple that almost got
out
the pitch to segura swinging a chopper
to third racing in on it evers he gloves
on the run he throws to first ball game
over what a night for workmen and the
red sox they blast off 11-5 the final
they win the opener